I want to share horror stories with you
because many of you have have been here
in in the horror story realm where
things have seemed to be going really
well and then behind the door
don't look so you've got something that
you put together that you thought was
gonna work out pretty well
it's brilliant it really works well
everybody loves it you've done all your
cloud deployment you've got your load
balancers and your EC twos and all that
cloud engineering stuff it's great
only it actually isn't great you got a
whole lot of servers that are really
slow and what went wrong you may have
some kind of thing that is you know wait
wait it's oh yeah that's right it's it's
slow you may have some analytical thing
that you put together and you know
you've done all the regular data science
you've done your homework you've got a
model that is really really good and it
is got a lot of explanatory power and
people really love it but you discover
that you know when it comes to running
the training it's slow so the first
thing you do the first thing everybody
does is you say it's that damn Python
it's just it's an interpreted language
we know the consequence of being an
interpreted language means it's
inherently slow right no no it's not
really true well if you're using pandas
or numpy it's really blazingly fast
you've got other problems and and the
problems are not really language based
problems so you do what everybody does
nowadays and I'm old and I'm gonna get
out my launcher and I'm gonna sit in my
launcher and shake my fist and helpless
fury because I remember the days before
stack overflow and none of you children
remember those days when you had to look
stuff up oh wait there's actually a I
old people
yeah it looks tough up in paper books is
anybody remember
so anyway so you go to stack overflow
and you say what the heck my thing is
really bad and everybody in stack
overflow piles on the same useless
advice run profiling no I didn't want
profiling I wanted code I couldn't copy
and paste this is the value proposition
of stack overflow is copy and paste code
that I just have to copy and paste and
want to do thinking and analytical work
on my code this is crazy
but after you actually do the work you
discover what what the problem is that
it really is the database and so we wind
up in horror movie trope world there is
a monster it is in your base and it is
eating your dudes right now and the
monster is your database this is the big
bottleneck that big data all suffers
from is your database is sort of slow
sometimes and it's not your code it's
this other thing the database thing and
it is largely opaque to most of us I
used to be a DBA and so I had a certain
privileged level of knowledge and I can
tell you databases are largely opaque
you can work with them for years and
still never understand how all the
moving parts and pieces fit together so
what I want to advise anybody who works
with data pie data that would be pretty
much all of us that there is some hard
work that needs to be done to defeat
this monster it will involve stress but
it also involves a fair amount of
garden-variety techniques that just have
to be applied appropriately I'm not
going to go through the techniques here
I'm going to talk about some some other
related stuff because the techniques
whether or not you add an index is you
know in sequel it's a create index or in
in [ __ ] it's a different kind of create
statement to the index do you
normalization is a powerful powerful
tool under-recognized but when you look
at a star schema design for analytical
data it's already denormalized there's
too much more you can do on that road
io concurrency is a thing everybody
wants to do and they hope it will help
if you're using desk in many cases that
happens sort of secretly and
automagically and it's a wonderful
wonderful thing data compression it
turns out surprisingly can have a
performance boost but whether or not it
does or doesn't is a profiling question
that you can't answer a priori you have
to do some experimentation oh wait you
have to do hard work so the question is
what does of that hard work look like
how do I find and kill that database
monster and the real question is is
there prevent in prevention techniques I
can use spoiler alert that's why I'm
here so in order to avoid having your
project evolve into a horror movie trope
there are two pieces of advice and they
are these simulate early and simulate
often and I want to emphasize the
gigantic value of what some people call
synthetic data you're gonna make up fake
stuff to seed your database with to
experiment with before you start trying
to use live data by the time you get
live data in there it's sometimes a
little late because now we have
commitments and we're going to do real
work with this database and it's slow
and that's an awful position to be in
where people think it's usable but it's
not really because the engineering work
didn't really get done in the beginning
it's now getting done after the fact the
monster is already in the house eating
your dudes and you're trying to figure
out what the monster even is
so there's a medium blog post here on
our external blog about using synthetic
data for some actual machine learning
training exercises kind of a clever way
of modeling something and generating
data and using the modeled data as a
training set this is related but it's
not really the same thing I want to talk
more specifically about some some more
concrete things we can do in the
simulation of the database as a whole
and I want to talk about things like
looking behind the door and never
running into the dark barn alone I have
trouble watching horror movies because
it's like duh don't do that there's
things like you know the trackless
forest after dark like who even well you
know these things happen the important
thing I think is to stay with friends
I'm really reluctant even to split up
from my partner in the grocery store why
don't you go get the milk in the ice
cream no no that I know what happens
when we split up even in the grocery
store not doing it so and the other
thing is that the funny noises really
really matter a lot because there are
those things that you noticed in one of
the early sprints where I had a test
case with 20,000 rows and it took a long
time so instead of fix the root cause
problem which was the monster behind the
door eating your dudes you cut the test
case down to a dozen rows all right
there was a funny noise and you ignored
him so of course the monster is eating
you sidebar conversation on this that
does come up occasionally some people
will tell you that you know really user
experience is far more important than
database scalability and whatnot no that
is wrong the UX may be important for a
lot of things but but the bottom line is
the data lasts forever
nobody saves the user
experience in an archive in 10 years
from now nobody is gonna be wondering
which button did I click no they want
the data that data is what mattered that
data was the only thing that mattered
therefore we probably ought to invest
some more time in the data engineering
the same way we invest a huge amount of
time in user experience engineering
they're both really valuable the data
has a longer life and therefore probably
ought to be looked at more closely and
clearly the whole life cycle of the
project so two pieces of advice simulate
early simulate often I firmly believe
even if it's a web services thing not
necessarily big data we're just like
persons filling in a form and we're
gonna go and run this thing that's gonna
start a kubernetes cluster and that's
gonna go run this other thing and it's
going to trigger off air flow where was
the data and that was just a transaction
still the data that requests to execute
all of those moving pieces and parts
that mattered a lot build the data model
for that as soon as you possibly can
argue about the data model first and
argue about it as we say later often
build a little nucleus of processing
this is Python world the nucleus of
processing ought to not be too much code
you just build some stuff and you play
with it on your desktop as soon as you
possibly can
I have because I've been around for a
few years I used to work a building
military equipment which meant you were
building embedded software that went
into like like radars which we're going
to be deployed in strange places I built
radars that we're gonna be deployed on
the North Slope of Alaska and there
would be no human being in that radar
completely unattended very sophisticated
machine you spend a lot of time like a
year in software design doing design
walkthroughs and stuff like that before
you commit to code that's not this world
that was in the 1980s it is now two
thousand and something eighteen I guess
we can build software during the meeting
where the users are standing there
saying I need to do this that and the
other thing well let me just hack some
garbage together right here and now
because I can so let me build the data
model right away in some useful software
form ideally in Python so that I can
start putting together a performance
testing environment right now so that
then I can go to the coffee shop where
I'm supposed to be working but I'm not
really working but then I can come back
the next morning and I can put a
realistic fake volume of simulated data
in there and we can discuss rationally
scalability and we haven't invested too
much in doing the wrong thing yet
because we're still experimenting with
Python that is the strong suit of this
toolset
so simulate early as soon as you
possibly can't build the data model in
some form and I'll show you some
techniques for this in a little bit and
simulate often every time the data model
changes and not like you know every time
no if real time I'm just gonna add a
field it's just an integer who even
cares stop will that really have no
performance impact do you have
measurements that show that just adding
an integer to this table will have no
impact get the measurements well add the
integer I ran some simulated data of
fifty million rows it hardly had any
impact it only ran for like a minute
longer all right that's good now we have
data we can do that simulate often if
you have a little nucleus model that
you're using performed for performance
testing then new features can be sort of
folded into the little nucleus model and
you can have fake timing loops and fake
processing loops and stuff because you
don't want to write the whole app twice
but the point is realistic volumes of
data this is the thing that gets all of
us who were DBAs in a former life it
gets all of us in trouble is that the
bigger your data the more places it's
spread around to the more processing
involved in getting the data out of its
persistent storage into memory
at all costs it's all got hidden costs
and it's got derivative costs and it's
got come founding factors in the cost
structure it's very complicated and
difficult to predict
so don't predict it simulate it see what
happens and as I mentioned more than
once
Python makes this particularly easy so I
want to talk a little bit about building
candidate data models and building
nuclei of processing and I'm very very
excited by the way restful api is and
crud processing parallel each other I
think that's exciting stuff
analytical ETL processing is also
exciting fun stuff what you're gonna
want to build eventually is some kind of
synthetic data generator sadly I don't
have a really cool open source project
for this there are some cool open source
projects for data generators and all
what I want to do is lay out how simple
this is maybe you need uh somebody
else's project or maybe you just slap
something together that will generate
data for you and move on as quickly as
you can you're also gonna want to
eventually do some measurements and you
know the built in time perf counter
didn't tell you everything you need to
know about performance you're not
measuring a lot of subtle things you're
just trying to say is this index
structure on the database faster or
slower than another candidate index
structure and you're just going to be
running sort of you know ongoing
experiments trying different things it's
a lot like one of those base and hopping
exercises where you're just going to try
a bunch of different permutations until
one of them is better so if you've got a
complicated data model done in like
sequel alchemy or the the Django ORM or
something like that then you've got a
really good data model those are pretty
tight um they're not actually good
enough for doing simulation but they're
okay as a starting place if you're using
data classes and Python 37 which is a
very exciting thing I'm loving those
they are like the other things okay
they're not all the way there if you're
using plain old Python objects or you
know
and like Jason or yamo serialization
they're okay but all of these things are
lacking some details and the issue is
that you generally only have minimal
type definitions string how big a string
what kind of characters in the string
how much redundancy in the string if I'm
gonna have a string representation of
dates they tend to begin with one
followed by nine or fois two followed by
zero and so indexing tends to go right
down the old Perl it because your
strings all look a lot alike if you just
generate like Rando data they don't look
a lot alike because your random number
generators are really good so ordinary
sequel table definitions ordinary sort
of class data class kind of type
definitions in Python don't give you
enough information there's no ranges
there's no enumerated values there's no
patterns there's really nothing primary
and foreign key constraints is about all
you have you have a little bit of extra
of information in some places but it's
really it's not enough so my suggestion
is for everybody you really want very
very narrow type specifications and I
think so far the optimal way to do this
is start using JSON schema for well
everything so here's here's what I I
like to aim for these kinds of things I
have there's a blog post that shows what
this model hypothetical model class
looks like it's a meta class that that
uses JSON schema to validate the the
object initialization time and so the
meta class initialization the json
schema validation that's built it takes
the Yambol version of the type
specification in can
that the actual document built in dunder
and knit fits the the specification if
it fails to fit the specification it
raises an exception and you can't create
an instance and if it fits it fits yeah
we have an object performance is of
course limited by the performance of the
json schema validator but the point is
not the performance of creating objects
the it's the retrieving them off the
database is the important part so in
this case I've used Hamel notation to
create the fool thing and I've got
fairly narrow type definitions so the
suit here the suit of a card I there are
an enum and those are the four strings
in front of God and everybody that is
the domain of values no options no
choices no doubts no questions so when
it comes to building synthetic data
moveable to those are the four strings
no doubts when it comes to building
database indexes and things like that
when it comes to building search strings
for your document store those are the
four values and there's no two ways
about this anymore we're not talking
Rando strings or arbitrary strings or I
don't know what kinds of strings no it's
those four characters and so that
severely limits the way indexing is
gonna work and you're gonna have to make
sure that you've got a data model that
handles the indexing correctly over that
domain as opposed to an imaginary domain
or a general-purpose domain so I
mentioned the the model class there you
know uses the Yambol a module to turn
the yam L into the document structure
that the json schema validator uses and
you know that there's a abstract class
that will use the dunder init to
validate the document and the so the
metaclass looks a little bit like this I
don't want to like I say I don't have a
great project for this but it's really
very straightforward in that I'm gonna
create this global variable they're not
a global variable but am a class level
variable schema with the schema object
in it and I'm going to create another
class level method there validator
pulled right out of the json schema
structure the new version 300 of JSON
schema now
up to draft seven validators for all the
new fancy features that they've been
adding to the json schema specification
the 2.6 version only has up to draft for
your mileage will vary depending on what
of those features you want to use but
we're gonna need to extend the whole
thing anyway and I'll show you the
extensions in a second so here is sort
of the superclass just uses the meta
class and it provides the important to
the all-important dunder and net which
does whatever initialization we're gonna
do in this case it's a subclass of dict
and it's gonna run the validator on that
dictionary if the dictionary is valid
according to the json schema validation
we're good otherwise I don't know type
error it's not good and it looks like
this when you use it so I'm gonna build
an object you know from a JSON string if
I want to do that or I could build the
objects individually it can do lots of
things but I get when I try to give it a
invalid thing so here I had suit is he8
RRTs not the letter capital H we get a
type error we get a detailed validation
error out of JSON schema so I have a
pretty tight control over what the
objects look like the point is of that
stuff that sort of sidebar is the json
schema lets us provide the type string
number integer that kind of thing it
gives us a place to put ranges in which
ordinary sequel doesn't have a great way
to handle it gives us enumerated values
for strings which sequel has no
capability of specifying it allows us to
put in formats and other sorts of
properties like red x's for Strings so
that we can really narrow those
constraints around what that data looks
like and the text patterning which is
kind of awkward to work with but it is
certainly possible so we can have a
bunch of constraints around the data so
that we know more specifically and very
narrowly what that domain of data looks
like so once we have embraced json
schema and maybe written a meta class or
something to handle the json schema for
us now we can move on to the
bits and the good bits are aha
I can leverage that JSON schema to
generate synthetic data that is the
point and it's not really very hard to
do the hardest part about it is deciding
to use JSON schema in the first place
and then going through the agony of
getting json schema specifications
organized for your model objects which
some people object to and some people
find difficult and and that's hard work
well it's all hard work I'm sorry about
that but the monster is behind the door
whether you do the work or not the
question is are you going to get eaten
by the monster behind the door and the
answer is do the work so that you don't
get eaten within JSON schema there's
these six types of data here there's a
there's a null there are integers and
integers have can have an enumerated set
of values and they can also have
minimums and maximums numbers are the
floating-point version again they can
have an enumerated set of values and
minimums and maximums strings oh my god
strings are complicated there are arrays
which are essentially Python lists and
objects which are essentially Python
dictionaries the what's going to happen
is as you start to think about how these
schema objects work is how you're going
to generate fake data for them what your
source of that fake data might need to
be and how you're going to be using
either random numbers or sets of pre
generated things to to pick values
according to these those are all the
ones you have to solve for there's not
very many it's not that complicated
so what you wind up with is code that
would look something like this
where when I am looking at generating a
fake record the the generate method down
here at the bottom you know is the what
kind of schema is it I'm gonna actually
plug the damn type into the middle of a
string to build a function name on the
fly this is despicable code by the way
my PI hates you when you do this but oh
my god it's so simple I'm gonna build
the function the method name
on the fly Jen underscore whatever
string or null are integer number or
whatever and then I'm just gonna run
that method and generate an example of
that value and so for arrays and objects
there's a recursion because you have to
generate the individual items within the
array or the object and the other guys
are just primitive so generating an
integer you just pull up the range
things and generate an integer it's not
that hard well it's a little hard but
it's not that hard and so the point
being that once I have decided how I'm
gonna populate integers and strings and
numbers and whatnot I can generate
synthetic data relatively simply by
handing this generator class a JSON
schema and turning it loose and out
drops documents and so you know I want a
generator for a particular schema I'm
gonna iterate over the documents
generated and I can do what I want
load them up in yamo files or write
about two JSON files or stuff him in a
[ __ ] database or make CSVs out of him
or whatever it is I got to do do a bunch
of Oracle inserts whatever the right
thing to do with that data is to
populate my fake database with enough
fake data that fits the schema really
really tightly the integers are real
integers in the right range the floating
point numbers are not between 0 & 1 but
they're like dollar amounts or whatever
it is that you needed to simulate to get
your model to reflect the future reality
of your application or the future
reality of your data science processing
so you use this kind of tool set the
JSON schema a little bit of Python code
to simulate early and often to make sure
your stuff is very likely to work that
if there is a monster behind the door
you know how big it is you know how long
the claws are you know how many teeth it
is and you know what the growling noise
is gonna be like so that you can then
say oh yeah we didn't simulate that
correctly or oh yeah we thought there
was going to be these but it turns out
there were those or oh yeah we have
irregular date format some begin with
two O's and some don't begin with two
O's and you know
what do we do about the fact that the
index doesn't work right anymore these
are things that we can explore in depth
without having to be waking up at 2:00
in the morning for production problems
because the jobs not running so really
sophisticated data domains is where
you're aiming with this just string or
just string with like a little pattern
thing no no no no real deal is natural
language kinds of items names and
addresses comment text some of these
things are not just simple Rando things
you're gonna have to write yourself some
fairly sophisticated generators to make
data that looks realistic ly like the
stuff you're gonna handle so one of the
ones that happen sometimes is string
processing where you know if the schema
had a constant value you'll return the
constant value duh if the schema had an
enum you pick one out of the enum and a
flat choice is probably fine for the
most part if they gave you a format well
now you're gonna have to go format by
format did schema say the format is an
email I gotta make a fake email did the
schema say it was a fake URL I gotta
make a fake URL they don't look alike
they don't index the same they don't
have the same properties that are the
same lengths so you're gonna wind up
with code like this sometimes where oh
the format's a date/time Oh God in
heaven I have to make a fake date well
it's not that hard to do but the fact
remains that you're not making a Rando
string you're making a fake date string
so you're digging in fairly deeply to
the types of data that you really expect
to see in your database and when you are
doing more complicated database
processing like full-text search and
full text indexing these are things that
[ __ ] does for you things that Oracle
does for you random strings are not
really completely appropriate they have
to look like the real thing so that your
performance numbers are right credit
card numbers are 10 digit strings so
you're gonna wind up with the need for a
random generator that looks like this
where I'm going to generate a string of
digits of a given length JSON schema is
not really good at describing this it's
kind of okay at describing this but
you're gonna have to ramp it up a little
bit by doing some extensions for things
like names people's names and stuff I'm
a big fan of just taking a big block of
lorem ipsum text and slicing and dicing
that to come up with words that are sort
of Latin based of varying lengths that
look kind of realistic they're not a lot
like total name names I don't know if
aerials in here now but one of my my
co-workers Ariel's got the most
complicated name in the world with two
different punctuation marks and at two
different punctuation marks - and an
apostrophe and so for the love of God
simulating that is really hard and it's
often disappointing because he puts
himself in his test data and oh I didn't
that validate yeah the aerial problem he
has lots of punctuation marks in his
name and we forgot to account for that
how awkward and he's right here
listening to me
more awkward still so you need to think
about the data domains sometimes very
deeply and an ordinary generic synthetic
data generator might not cover the bases
very well because you're gonna have
things that are deeper more complicated
more problem specific and
reverse-engineering the json schema to
emit data is in that heart that's not
really that difficult so you can
leverage json schema to generate your
own fake data so that you can model your
databases so the way to get yourself in
deep and profound trouble is to have
faith
that you already know the right solution
and it is as a practicing former
practicing DBA
I can tell you there are many DBAs that
will tell you many things about
databases that are tried-and-true thing
that they have a great deal of faith in
but no metrics awkward so when you make
assumptions you make an ass out of you
and me no no way it's spell assumption I
make an ass out of you an option no no
no wait anyway making assumptions about
the data is probably wrong probably have
real examples of the data making
assumptions about the data praise
performance is doubly wrong because
you've assumed the data you've assumed
the data model oh wait it's maybe it's
Triple E wrong you've assumed how they
the the query processing is gonna go
you've made a lot of assumptions none of
which are validated by actual experience
so basically the problem is that hope is
going to get you in a lot of trouble
measurement is going to avoid the
trouble so look behind the door do not
run into the darkened barn alone it's
the first sprint of the production
increment why can't we do this right now
maybe we should do a little engineering
may be a technical spike is better than
racing into the darkened barn all by
yourself I strongly recommend technical
spikes the trackless forest well we
never did this before with this
particular database product good idea
yeah let's just charge into the forest
with no track in front of us that'll
work out well I'm sure stay with your
friends and so you're gonna have to work
cooperatively with the analytic
community that is using your data and
the data sourcing community that is
providing your data and making sure that
the stuff goes into the database and
comes out of the database in a
respectable fashion so this requires a
lot of hard work and a lot of
cooperation and above all do not dismiss
the funny noises that if we can't get a
unit test or an integration test to work
this is indication that maybe we've got
bigger engineering problems and we maybe
should have had a spike sooner which we
can't go back and retroactively lis do
so maybe we need to slow some
down change course maybe admit that
version 1.0 is gonna have scalability
issues and and take a divergent paths so
that version 1.1 doesn't have the same
scalability issues there's a lot of
things we need to do but the most
important of them is not to dismiss the
funny noises that if it looks a little
odd measure measure measure so simulate
early and often you can do this with
Python classes really quickly really
easy data classes are fun and easy to
use using JSON schema is even better so
you make yourself a little meta class
you put the JSON schema in there you
validate documents and you can use the
JSON schema to build synthetic data and
you then can actually gather hard
performance data real things the real
database on a real server if it's cloud
based you spin the server up you run the
thing and you shut the server down yeah
that's the most fun ever because I can
remember when we had to buy hardware and
you had to know in advance a year in
advance how big a server you're supposed
to buy based on what I haven't even
finished talking to the users we don't
even have UX stories yet and you want me
to specify Hardware those were the bad
old days now we can try it on for size
and we can say oh the 64 core is doing
pretty well but I think I can get it
down to a 32 core if I rearrange the
indexes a little bit yes and that is how
you make the most money out of the
technology that you have at hand thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
since it's lunchtime I would prefer to
take questions out in the hall if
anybody has any and I'll meet you out at
the lunch line